um hello and good afternoon and thank
you for having us
for having uh yeah hosting and for
hosting us in this exciting
collaboration
so today our talk will be about yeah
building the future of sports analytics
together between psv and html um these
two seemingly different companies
uh we've yeah we have an exciting
collaboration uh
to tell you about how we merged the
world of high tech which is asmr
with the challenges in in football in
specific and
yeah we hope you enjoyed the talk as
much as we do enjoyed the collaboration
and i hope we get you get you
enthusiastic throughout this talk
so before we start about the content
it's my
honor and my pleasure to introduce you
to the hosts of today
so not the full team is here today but
who is on the far left of your screen
uh he's the head of sports science and
analytics at psc
and he's also been our product owner if
you will during this collaboration so
he's our main point of contact
he will be sharing the insights into the
the exciting world of football and the
opportunities of analytics and football
as well
and on the right you see the asml team
who's been participating in this
collaboration um goldblum will be here
today
and maybe he may be he may be listening
in hopefully
mouth and mouth was a data full stack
data scientist data engineer
uh in our innovation lab and she will do
the
technical part of the of the talk and
then on the far right of your screen
the the one left that's myself so my
name is daddy
rick i'm the product owner of our
analytics innovation lab
and which we actually used as the
incubator for this project
together with psv so i'm not going to
share much of the content itself but
i'm hooked here to answer your questions
on this collaboration as well
so as many of you know um asml is
actually part of
this metropol region brainport eindhoven
partnership
and part of us being a shirt sponsor
for psv we're also uh yeah we're also
very much willing to share the knowledge
of
how we work and the knowledge we have at
asml with psv
and that also comes back from psv to
asml
so we really started to extend the
partnership just from sponsoring also to
actually collaboration but where do you
start right
um and we noticed in our talks with psv
that they have a specific vision or
strategy or ambition
on data science well and i translate it
here because the original goals were in
dutch
freely translated so hope doesn't get
angry with me
and it was actually three bullets so
develop data science products in the
cloud
yeah hot topic right now apply data
science to solve complex puzzles and
players performance
how do we use these techniques to model
player performance or improve player
performance even
and apply the newest research especially
a very odd topic which
we'll tell you more about in a minute
which is outside of psv or outside of
asml and it's maybe even an open source
community
is available and how can we apply that
to ps3
well obviously very large challenges
right especially cloud engineering and
these topics
but how do you take these topics and
apply them to psv
well incomes are departments so both mao
and myself are part
of what we call the it competent center
big data analytics
actually the number is not correct we're
now over 300 people mainly focusing on
uh provisioning data so both our machine
data
which obviously goes in the realm of
terabytes of data
generated per day per machine and
so we have a lot of colleagues focusing
on the data engineering part and
yeah specifically our competence which
is innovation moving fast collaboration
across advanced analytics we merged
those two
and there we saw the yeah almost
imagined in heaven if if i can call it
this way where the challenge of psv and
asmr's execution power and knowledge on
executing these projects
so what did we do i'm not going to talk
you through the process we actually
built what we call a proof of value
where we used
our innovation lab as the incubator and
uh yeah obviously we've used
yeah we started literally from a very
rough idea
which will tell you and build the result
of what you're about to see
in just actually yeah in just three
months
we will talk you through what we've
built how we've built it in the next
yeah probably 20 minutes and then we
will discuss what's next
on there yeah hopefully in the future a
lengthy collaboration
so i guess for you to to share psv's
dream
yes thanks drake i will try to take over
the screen
um and then hopefully
everybody can see it i'm working from
home but i use my computer at work so
it's a little bit tricky but i think
everybody can see the screen now
um so yeah i want to start uh the story
from our side with uh
with an example of a game that we played
a couple months back this is probably
for the people that watch football game
that they might remember
we drawn against arden hack a couple
weeks back a game that ended in 2-2 but
i think if we would have played this
game uh a couple more times that
would have looked a little bit
differently and looking at the
let's say the standard stats that are
available in the football elixir
or analysis world it paints a pretty
strange picture so
again the game ended in two two um
but if you look at the amount of shots
five from other one goal or five from
auto in total 35 from psv
otto shot on goal two times and they
scored two times unfortunately
we shot 15 times and also ending up in
two goals um
we had 72 percent of ball possession way
more passes way more corner kicks so
if you look at this from i think from a
neutral perspective you would think
this is probably a game that psp wins
but in the end we didn't so what's
happening here and why is this happening
and
uh i think part of the story here and i
think that's something we
often forget in football is that there
also may be a little bit of luck
involved in
the case like this so this is actually a
picture that we stole from uh from a
book from a couple years back
um and in in this few studies there was
an estimation done on how much skill and
luck is involved in in specific games
and if you look at the scale completely
on the left you have a lottery or
roulette game which are completely
lock based and on the right side you
have chess which is
uh yeah i think completely almost
completely a skill based game
and you see a couple different sports on
that
on that skill as well with football
being a little bit more to the right
side
um maybe a question we can ask the
audience if you can answer it quickly in
the chat why do you think
nfl mlb and nhl are more to the left
compared to to soccer in this case of
football
if people have an id then please do a
shout out in the chat
and i'm trying if i can
see the check so one hit maybe
uh yeah i think the the most important
answer is already
there but it's
yeah the more or higher scores is a very
important thing in this case but then
again
if you look for instance at uh nfl or
mlb
they actually may make more points in
football but still they are more to the
left so for mbas
you're completely right um you score 100
points in an nba game and you end up way
more to the
towards the skill side so scoring more
points will make a game more skill based
um but i think the right answer is still
not here no
the main thing in here uh i will uh i
will tell you the secret
is the competition structure so in mlb
nfl and any cell the ending standing in
the league is decided by playoffs
and so a playoff at the end of the
season decides
whether a team will be the champion and
of course if you
decide the champion over a single or a
few games uh
there's more luck involved than compared
to a season where you do that in
uh in a whole in a whole season table so
that's why football is a bit more to the
right side so if the players will be cut
out of the other sports
football would be a pretty high uh
log base part and it's estimated from
the from these papers
and then in football about 31 percent of
the end score of the league table is
based on luck
so what we try to do as a performance
department or as a sports science and
analytics department
within psv is trying to control the 69
that we really have influence on
so again the auto game there might have
been a bit of look and fall but of
course if we would have
completely influenced the 69 that we can
uh
we hopefully win this these games in the
future and that
what's what we are focusing on today um
if you look at
uh other initiatives worldwide there's
quite a bit of open source analytics
um things available
uh right now and i think one of the best
examples are the bars innovation up
uh with a few very good people there and
also the the guys that are doing some
work at liverpool
and what actually came out of uh mainly
the liverpool side was a
model that was called pitch control and
this is actually a model um
that we were trying to implement we
couldn't really figure it out and that's
why we we
uh we asked help from asml to to really
do this
um i will start with showing a little
demo
uh shortly uh on what we ended up
building
and then afterwards miles will take over
from me to explain you the
the technical details of this um and i
want to start with a little video
and to give you some context i will play
it locally because
it was not really working in the youtube
video so hopefully everybody can see it
now
it's already starting i have to go back
i will play it a couple of times so
we have some context so this is from our
game against paxwell from
from a while back we end up scoring uh
via mario goods in the end
um but take your time to
see what's happening here and i will
play it another time for some for more
con so it starts out with the goalie
having the ball
throwing it out to the side and we
immediately start pressuring something
that we would like to see from our
players this is really
what we hope for in our playing style we
take over the attack then we get a
little bit of help from a defender from
zwolle
mario takes over in the back outplays
the goalie in his course
so please keep this uh this in mind and
then we will go to
the end application that we that we
build on this and mode will explain
like i said afterwards what really what
really happened here uh from the
beginning so i will
again go back to that first situation so
we have
the goalie here with the the yellow ball
in his hands
and if we play this this data stream um
then you will see what is happening here
on the bottom you see the amount of
area that we control on the pitch and
why that's important that we will come
back to that later but this is what we
ended up building in this project so
here again you see pablo rosario taking
over we have the ball take over the
attack
we play back mario comes in the back
outplays the goalie and score so this is
a 2d visualization
of the data of that specific goal that
we just saw and then i would like to
hand it over to mao to give some more
context to this and i will explain later
how we try to use this within our
environment
i think mode is still muted i see the
screen now but yeah
sorry i was looking for a good button
hopefully you can all see
my screen now yes thank you yeah and
so uh rude just showed you the end
visuals
and now we'll take you with how we
actually started
so with like with every um
data project the first thing we did is
looking at the data
so what data do we have do we have to
deal with data
and psv has access to multiple data
sources
and one of the data sources is event
data
and event data is all about events that
take place at the ball
you can think about an event as one
player passing the ball to another
player
but also an attacking action or an
attempted goal
are also called events and did
this data is manually entered by people
who are
actually watching the game so you can
imagine that it's quite prone to human
errors
and can result in incorrect data or
missing data and
this results in approximately 2 000 rows
per mesh next to the event data psv has
also accessed to tracking data
and tracking data is all about the exact
x and y location
of all players and the wall in the field
and this data is automatically obtained
from
cameras that are available in all
individual stadiums
and is obtained 25 times a second
because it's automatically obtained of
course this data is more
reliable than the event data and it
results in
approximately four million rows per
match
to be able to calculate a pitch control
as we just showed we had to
do some pre-preparation steps and you
can think about
some steps as in combining some tracking
data files to
transform files to clean files and
combine into one
easy to handle data frame but we also
had to
for one of the use cases we had to join
the event data and the tracking data so
that you join the data
based on names but also based on
timestamps
and since one dataset is obtained
manually and the other one
is obtained automatically it was quite a
challenge to match those data
resources but at the end we found a
solution for that
and so let's now move on to the pitch
control
so this image is a copy of what you just
saw in the demo of fruit and pitch
control is all about
how well psv is controlling the fields
so you see some red area which is
a psv and the opponent in blue
and yeah you can see that the red area
is controlled by
psv and in some areas you see more blue
and that's of course
controlled by the opponents and i'll now
explain you how we actually
calculated this and we made use of
um uh of a script of a
student of the team of eindhoven which
is actually based on a paper of spearmen
so we could reuse this script and also
the steps taking in the script of course
we had to
make it fit to our use case but
at least it is about next steps
so the first step of course you have to
do to calculate this control
is initialize the home and the weight
layers in this case
these v is visualized in red and
opponents in blue
and ball in yellow and then the
second step is initializing player
characteristics and this is quite
important first one of course
is the position of the player but also
the velocity
and the direction of the player are very
important in calculating
pitch control other characteristics of
players are for example the reaction
time and the maximum speed of a player
for this use case we just have the same
reaction time and maximum speed for
every
player but in a more advanced uh
next step we could also initialize this
for all individual players
there was also a time to intercept and
probability
intercept of the ball and yet this is
more technical and also explained in
this paper of spearmen
and then the third step in calculating
pitch control is breaking the pitch
down into a grid so in this case we had
1600 boxes in one
for the fields and and then the step is
to calculate for each
box in this grid is calculating the
bishop control
so if for example this box is called
red because player 2 will
be the first and be the fastest at this
box
in time so you can calculate the pitch
control for every player
so if you have a look at for example the
boxes around player 4 they are all
colored blue because this play will
reach this
square the first or the fastest
but for example just one box just after
player 4 is called
red but this is because player 3 already
has direction
uh to this box and this is why
it's red and it's more uh
yeah for psv is in charge
and of course we can calculate this for
the whole page for every
box in the grid which results in this
picture
so we have to calculate the pitch
control for x each
box which is like 1600 boxes in a grid
multiplied by 25 frames a second so we
had to do quite a lot of
calculations to get an id of one match
and of course we could also aggregate
this data and calculate the average
pitch control
per seconds or by match
um so that's about page control
maybe you can elaborate a bit on how
this is useful for pc and
what were the next steps
so so maybe not because as you're
switching to root there's a question the
front which might be useful which was um
how does the pitch control report for
the minutes 9193
for the other game look like just out of
curiosity if the other goal was sheer
luck
or was it high pitch control so maybe
that's not for you but maybe leading
towards root's talk
but happy if you want to share some
comments here yeah i think it's a
very nice visualize in the it's a blow
demo but then we have to go
back to this uploading there you can see
that
the player is actually making more space
and that pitch control is also changing
in colors
i'm not sure if you can show it
we cannot hear you
now you can again sorry um so from that
specific game i don't have the data
available right now because we
we the question was about about this
game that we just had the example of of
course
that extreme game um but i think the
question really was
um would it would it really change in
those minutes and i think around that
that minute of the goal that would
definitely be something interesting to
look at but we haven't done that yet
um so if i'm continuing
um of course what you just saw was of
course a really uh
interesting picture already that you can
visualize the amount of space that is
that a player or a whole team in the end
is controlling over the game
and that was already something that was
uh
the code was available uh open source
but the real applications of these were
still
a little bit unclear and we wanted to uh
take this to the next level actually and
see can we
move this really interesting and nice
visual of pitch control uh
and even live pitch control that we can
show over a game and move it towards
something that might be useful for
coaches and one of the first steps that
we were thinking about
was actually can we calculate the uh
contribution of a single player
or a single event towards pitch control
on a team level
so for instance can we estimate what the
influence of a certain pass is on pitch
control
so one of the first things that we that
we did there was
uh we have a specific example here from
that same game against swallow
and from the event data you can see we
actually took out the pass so this in
this case we have a pass from our right
uh center defender team obama geithel
towards our left backfield max
um and what we did what we tried to do
was actually uh
look into the amount of pitch control
that we have at this point in time just
before the pass so in this case we had
49.5
percent of the pitch in control and what
is happening
after that specific pass and so that we
gain or lose pitch control by giving
this specific
specific ball and of course we know that
there's a lot more
things that are influencing this because
there's 20 people moving on the page
that are influencing the control as well
but we wanted to see can we make an
estimation of
the amount that a player is contributing
with his passing towards
this pitch controller to make it a
little bit more
useful for coaches and to to try to get
it into their minds
so again keep this picture in mind 55.5
versus
45.9 in this picture then we go to the
next snapshot which is after
just after the pass you see on the left
top of
the boat screenshots that this is about
four seconds later that
philip box actually gained control of
the ball so the pass was good
and in that point in time we have 53.9
percent of the pitching control
and this means we gained 4.4 percent of
pitch control
uh with this pass and of course again
with the statement that of course that's
not the only thing influencing this
value
um so it might be a little bit of an
estimation in that case
so what we actually built on this is
actually something i want to show in the
blow again so i will move to
[Music]
my blow environment again um so what we
actually can do if we
uh we know this value for every single
pass and we see the amount of
contribution that a player has
what we can then do afterwards is of
course aggregate this over multiple
games or over multiple passes so in this
case you see the summary of
again that smaller game where you see
that on average
psv controlled 48.6 percent of the pitch
and back swallow 51.4
and if you look at the specific passes
for instance you see in this case pablo
rosario gave
58 passes in this game and he had a
total contribution of 187
so we gained pitch control with his
passing and the median contribution of
his boss was about 1.8 percent
um some other things that you can see
here is that francis philip bucks
actually
uh ended up losing control over the
pitch with his passing and
and still we don't really know if this
is a good or a bad thing
but what we do know is that this is a
new level of analytics that shows us
more information
than just a passing percentage uh i
think one of the biggest examples
that coaches always use is you see a
passing percentage from two central
defenders which are really high
but the only parts to watch each other
and there's no risk taking in their
passing
so they don't pass forward so that would
already be the next step so
how much passing is forward which can be
done but this would be an extra layer on
that
how much control are we gaining over
that pitch with that specific pass
this is also built in a way that this
can be filled over a game so let's say
you only want to see passes from the
second half
and this can all be done within a few
clicks
so that's actually the way that we
that we try to build a first um
usable uh implementation of the spread
control
uh and event data combination um
and there's already a few things that we
have in mind for for the future
so if we look at the next steps of of
this model
we are looking into of course improving
this by
for instance adding complexity to the
model in a way that you can say okay
certain parts of the pitch are more
important i will click back to a
previous sheet for this a little bit
so for instance if we look at at this
sheet at this point in time where team
obama recognized the ball
and of course the interesting part of
the pitch to control for us is the area
behind the last central defenders
so this is the area where we can
probably attack from and score from
so this area is probably in this
snapshot more important than the area
behind our own goalie for instance
because the ball is not there there are
no players from the opponent there so
giving value to
specific part of the pitch at a specific
point in time it's definitely
one of the next steps a second and a
really big thing and
also in this is to actually implement
the next step that's also described in
the paper
which is called epv or expected
possession value
in which you actually elaborate more on
this model with adding
um an expected goals model to it so for
the people that do know expected goals
models
what you are actually going to do then
is actually calculating the chance that
this snapshot of the game is
ending in a in a goal scoring
opportunity for us
so how much is the chance that we score
a goal from this specific situation
and if you can do that then of course
you have even more added value because
you then
not only can deliver a new interesting
step but you can really
calculate the probability that we are
going to end up scoring a goal which is
of course way more important than
um than any other thing in football in
the end
and as we went through this project we
already saw that actually doing this and
being able to combine these different
data streams in this way actually just
ended up giving us way more questions
than we started with in the beginning
um so i think discovering uh other
tactical uh
possibilities of analysis is uh is yeah
definitely open for the future now
and this project mainly stated for us
that the way we are doing this currently
is definitely the way to go and it makes
uh yeah makes
a lot of possibilities uh for us to to
analyze more in the future
and then uh from there i want to hand it
over to dietrich again because he will
show you
a little bit more about the technical uh
background of
what we did in this project so so maybe
as you're doing that transition there's
a couple of questions that came through
um so it gives deck some time to switch
over so the question one was
um how do you deal with pitch control
versus skill so
pitch control is nice but skills the
lead ball
do the work is maybe more important and
does this correlate in any way
yeah yeah probably of course as i said
before there's
definitely some things that we are now
not taking into account
in the model i think the easiest thing
to understand is is for instance there
is no
uh contribution and taken into account
for
for instance maximal speed of a player
or its maximum acceleration so we
estimate right now that all players are
equally fast and equally explosive so
that's definitely something to improve
on in the future
we already have some ideas on how to do
that but of course
every skill based uh kpi that you could
put in there would probably make a model
like this
uh like this better but then again it
will either take you a lot more data to
do it
and it's often not available on those uh
hard to grab
stats like some specific skill stats um
but yeah definitely true that that's
that's something that you
would like to take into account if
possible in the future right
so um so there's another question that
came through is um uh
someone noticed that um uh the weighting
of the goalkeeper so how are the values
around both keepers weighted
and since this could have a big
influence so um
can you share a few words on that or i
don't know
let's see the question that i i think
exactly the same as uh
as the other players if i i'm looking at
mouth maybe if she can elaborate on this
chest and id but i think it's the same
for the goalies for the other players
but then again like i said
taking into account uh some physical
characteristics
would definitely be a an improvement of
the model
yeah for now they are indeed all the
same but it is also a good metric to
compare
goalkeepers with each other we have all
data of all matches in the netherlands
so if you could calculate this
number for all goalkeepers and all teams
so then it's
good to compare goalkeeper with a
goalkeeper and not with
with another another player in the field
very good i think maybe one more quest
because i think that's a really
important one to answer i think that's
very very smart question from i think
triantos is what i see
uh that these medics are about scoring a
goal but what about if we want to
control the game or freeze the tempo in
the game
uh can you measure what's happening then
i think one of the big things that we
are currently also looking into not
specifically yet for this project but
also for some other stats
is something that we want to implement
in all our analytics is actually
what's something that's called game
state so what happens if your
two goals up or five goals behind that
of course completely changes the way you
play that game
so of course you're let's say your three
goals up ten minutes more to play you
will probably do something completely as
on if you're one goal behind you're
gonna
fully push to uh to get the one point
out of the game so what we are actually
doing right now in our databases is
we're gonna calculate
or we actually did it already and we
have calculated for every snapshot in
the game
what is the game state at that point is
the game draw are we behind are we in
front or are we multiple goals behind or
in front
so getting that into a model like this
will definitely also improve it because
it makes an amazing difference probably
uh on on the way you play so it's a very
very good question
very good thank you thank you rhodes so
dedic do you want to kind of continue
wrap it up for us yeah of course of
course let me take over the screen for
the final couple of
notes oh excuse me um
can you guys see my screen yep yep okay
all right um yeah just let me quickly
wrap up the
the final few closing remarks obviously
most of the questions will be regarding
uh yeah the model and the application of
football itself
but one of the key things which we were
able to do in the past couple of months
was
obviously this these calculations are
quite heavy right so
we obviously needed to look towards
either very expensive on-premise
infrastructure
or build a solution in the cloud and i'm
not going to go through all the details
but part of what we did was also show
psv what's possible if you take away the
limitations
of psv currency mainly focused on bi
environment right
so there's actually three components in
yeah where actually the models run and
all the engine there
were basically where the pipeline has
been built um
there's three components so the storing
the compute and the serving of the data
model
and using in this case azure because
obviously
we at asimo mainly invested into azure
also some first experiments and some
deployments already happening with gcp
but primarily azure and
gcp um we were able i think it was even
in a couple of days with a couple of
hours to completely mimic psv's
vi environment so deploying not just in
sql server so
basically deploying that backup but also
my sql server and
also ingesting their storage and so
ingesting all their raw files into a
storage account or within yeah obviously
within hours um
so there's one point which was really
really helpful for us um the second part
is the model the notebook mulches showed
it's
it's a jupiter notebook and it's written
in python
so in order to move fast and to learn
fast we needed a place where can we
industrialize these models
obviously we're throwing a lot of
computational power when we uh we
when we needed to go through uh to
calculate pitch control across multiple
matches
it made sense to look at spark to do it
so instead of deploying our own spark
cluster
using data breaks it actually took took
one or two hours to uh
to build it or actually deploy the
cluster and to deploy the notebooks to
obviously
modern experience in using buy spark so
she could use that api to translate the
python code into
pi spark code to take benefit to take
benefit of the spark power in there to
the parallelization power
that's when all the calculation happens
we write back the information to the
storage account
sorry we write back the data to the
storage account uh we used
parquet files to that uh for that
obviously um
compute is expensive so you actually
yeah i will get to that in a minute
and we store the files with parquet and
then a final hurdle we need to take
is psv the environment we just showed
we needed to get the results back to psv
as well so you needed some sql endpoint
through asmr's firewall and we used
synapse for that and the beauty of
synapse
it knows is it has this serverless sql
engine
you don't provision any any resources
you just fire off your sql query
on top of the parquet files and the load
doesn't even know that it's
not talking to an actual sql server and
you can run calculations across tens of
millions of
uh of rows in a database obviously it's
a virtual one
and the view of it tableau doesn't know
it's it's querying against
a virtual database we use these
components if you have any questions
about this
this is actually also the foundation of
what we're going to industrialize
probably this will be the direction and
to extend
the the proof of value on top of
[Music]
if you then look at what are the
benefits to us and this is actually
i really like this image this is where
you see the um
the beauty of cloud right so compute is
expensive and storage is cheap so
storing the files is almost
is almost for free and this is where you
can actually see the databricks cluster
spinning up so
we're basically paying for the compute
of the virtual machines and the
the smaller peak is of where we just
tested the
the calculation pitch control for one
match and the bigger peak
i think it was mount running over a
weekend was was running all the
calculations for the
uh for multiple matches and this is
really the beauty right so databricks is
expensive
and this is where you can really see the
beauty of having this basically infinite
scaling
these infant scaling options obviously
it's heavy calculations this i think
also one of the points
malta talked about improving these
calculations because
it's a lot of calculations happening at
the same time at 25 times a second so
improvements there
and really make the whole model of
calculations faster
but we're now able to throw just raw
compute at it
these notebooks i talked about already
so this really made it really fast take
the existing work and then mold it into
a notebook running on that on top of
databricks
and obviously when you create your own
little island in azure it's all in
completely segregated so it's a
completely there's a firewall around it
but it makes
easy integration if you use components
in the cloud
this is actually the final part we
wanted to talk about
and yeah i hope we got you inspired with
what you can actually achieve with these
two completely different companies we at
least not myself but we as asmr are used
to
creating these very very complex uh you
know this is an erv machine i think
and psv obviously mainly focused on
winning matches right
merge these two worlds together um and
i'm happy
to share that we will continue to work
together for at least uh
another year industrializing whatever we
built and really driving uh
uh yeah the future of sports analytics
at psv
and with this and with the van nisterhoy
in the back of the room i would like to
close
our talk and if you have any more
questions feel free to shout and thanks
again for having us
thank you very much it's a very
wonderful wonderful presentation so
don't go away because there are multiple
questions that came through some of them
you can see some of you can't so i'm
going to quickly share some of these
questions with you
and then you can choose between the
three of you who's best suited to answer
so um
ali khan he asked to what extent machine
learning plays a role in sports
analytics
at psv or in general so based on your
experience
um can you share a few words on that
um yeah and what we currently did not
yet
uh it's mainly focused on the
engineering part so machine learning
there's no
ai involved in it um but yeah
maybe you have an opinion on to what
extent do you think it will be
used in the future oh yeah there's
definitely a lot of possibilities to
think about of course but i think
if we look at this level of analytics
that at least the football world i won't
talk about other sports too much but um
at least the football
we are really at the beginning stages of
that so um
if you look at the amount of data that's
becoming available now mainly from
tracking providers it's just it's just
really starting
and a lot of clubs i i think are pretty
much in the same situation as we are
where they are
still really looking at okay how can we
handle especially the raw
the track data tracking data sets i
think quite a few clips already able to
work pretty well with with aggregated
data sets or summaries from what they
got from the games but
really looking into more complex ai
solutions over multiple games or even
multiple seasons is definitely something
that's
just starting to happen but there's
definitely a lot of future for it
so so um there's another question from
sham which kind of connects to what you
just said
is uh usually there's a retrospective
analysis of the games
and the question is what do you do with
this pitch control
and then the question really is got
multiple fronts and there's several
questions around this is
does this lead to new tactics do you
analyze this for your competitors do you
use that change the way the coach
behaves does that
change anything from the players and
maybe even another one that came through
is
will this play a role in your purchasing
patterns of new players and how much
you can put a price on a player so uh
lots of questions so maybe a very good
question i think we can talk about this
for a couple hours if we want to but
i think looking into what we are doing
right now for us this is really still
about understanding the game better
so i think the auto game is a perfect
example where you see that this
the the stats that we have available uh
like
let's say the classic stats are not
painting the whole picture so learning
about what football really
intends and i think um spearman also
called
his paper decomposing the immeasurable
game and i think that's still something
that's really true for football we are
still really learning
what's really happening in this game um
so for us it's definitely more
an understanding thing and i think
hopefully what you hope or what you want
to see
happening out of this is that these
models and the insights that we gain
from them are actually going to be
more than just descriptive about what
happened in a specific game but are
gonna be pretty
prescriptive about what should we do in
a specific training session to get a
player better or
what's gonna happen if we uh change this
player for for another one
or the question about scouting which
guys might be good
might be suitable for uh for ps3 in the
future so
um yeah that's definitely the hope for
the future that uh
where we are now really in a descriptive
phase of analytics that we can move
towards a more
uh prescriptive or predicting uh way of
working
yeah very good very good so um maybe
just two more questions and then what we
can do is we'll go to the amiibo
tropical island and
people can find you guys but uh one of
the questions was um
in the ai field it's quite common for
example in healthcare
that you tell doctors what ai can do and
you look at the data and you digest it
and you give insights to maybe
doctors within their lifetime looking at
this we're assuming the same thing
applies to football coaches right they
have
years of experience they paid the
question then is
how easy is it to trigger change based
on experience
professionals have done this for years
and decades of their lives
versus a smart team such as yourself
presenting valuable insights which
may or may not go against their gut
feeling how do you deal with that change
which in general i think is a good
question
yeah very good question uh yeah it's
something i've been dealing with over
the last 10 years working in football i
think
and you see that that broad really
changed um a very good example the
picture that
dietrich showed in the end uh from with
vanessa roy who's going to be our
coach for young people next year
currently on the 18th coach um he
actually came up and said i heard about
this project with asml
i want to talk to these guys and learn
from them
and i hope they don't know anything
about football because i just want to
pick their brains because they are
really smart and don't think about
football
so i think that's a little bit of the
that shows a little bit how the
generation of coaches changing
but still um coming back to that
question i think it's still really
important because the coaches do they do
have a good eye
and and we shouldn't forget that they
they probably see a lot of things that
are happening and that probably
computers still cannot see
um so of course it's really important
that we also give them
sometimes things back that really
help them in knowing that they are doing
the right thing so
that are putting emphasis on the things
they do right and of course
once in a while you have to throw
something into the room and say okay
this might be completely different than
what we were doing before
and which ends up being a very good
conversation then um but
of course you have to watch out a little
bit that you uh when you do that and and
how you time that
and and i think that's something that's
that's mainly important in a role
that i have at the club so i won't be uh
as technical as did they came out in
this project on on how to do
how to design these solutions but
knowing how to get them to watch the
coaches
and to watch the implementation that's
that's yeah that can be tricky sometimes
but that's that that's the challenge of
my job actually
very good so maybe just one last
question then we'll go to the tropical
island i know there are lots of them
through the question so i apologize for
those who
don't get it but this one came through
on a private message was uh
i think it's more from alex which is uh
you mentioned that 1600 blocks
and the question was why did you choose
1600 why not more and then the question
is
are these blocks weighted in any shape
or form so i we're assuming that uh
the pitch control closer to the goals is
worth or waited differently did you did
you consider that or is that part of
your
uh to do future state projects
yeah we considered it because indeed a
speech closest to the goal is more
important as who is already mentioned
but is not implemented in this use case
for now
uh just taking it step by step and
indeed
if you want to specify it even more you
could also
just make the grid even bigger with more
boxes in there just because of scoping
and time we choose
this uh basic setting actually